so I'm like I'm going to the school to
play ball and that's it I don't want
nothing to do with white people I don't
believe that they want anything to do it
I don't want no for as me and my boys
were going to high school together we
here to hook LeBron James admits he
didn't always trust white people to to
kind of adjust to it during the NBA
stars HBO show the shop he opened up
about life at his mostly white exclusive
private high school in Akron Ohio
that was like my initial like thoughts
in my initial shock to like white
America when I was 14 years old for the
first time in my life and he candidly
admits that when he first got to st.
Vincent st. Mary he had no intention of
befriending his white classmates like
when I first went to to the 9th grade in
the high school I was awesome like I'm
not going with white people right like
his my whole I was so institutionalized
growing up in the hood is like they
don't put us they don't want us to
succeed the hierarchy and then we're
here like matter of fact we underneath
this chair but maverick Carter LeBrons
business partner and besties since high
school chimed in explaining that it
didn't take long for that to change
and LeBron revealed the surprising thing
his white classmates introduced him to
first time I ever found out about a
pantry is when I went to high school
break right cereal right chips doughnuts
doughnuts all it is on the top of the
refrigerator when I got to high school
the first time I knew about a pantry
[Music]
[Applause]